- To anyone who says I'm too
young or girls can't do it,
I would say, "Come watch
a Monster Jam event.
"Watch me compete and watch me win."
(energetic music)
I'm Rosalee Ramer, the world's youngest
professional female monster truck driver.
When I first sat in the seat
of a monster truck, I was 11.
I started competing at age 14,
and I've been competing ever since.
I could drive a monster truck
before I could drive a car on the road.
I'm studying mechanical
engineering at Georgia Tech,
and I'm working on making the
monster truck of my dreams.
I'm working on lowering
the center of gravity
of the monster truck so
that it has better handling
and more capabilities when we're out there
on the field competing.
First I get an idea about
how I wanna improve a monster truck.
Then I put some of my ideas
down on paper in my sketch pad.
I get to put that into the computer
so I can work with it on a higher level,
and I get to 3-D print it.
Having a technical mind is definitely
an advantage on the field.
I know exactly how my truck works,
and it allows me to read
how it's doing on the track.
I can fix anything that's
wrong with my truck.
Wild Flower is the first
truck I got to help build.
Putting that pink, those
big flowers on my truck,
that really shows who I
am, and I'm proud of that.
And I hope that that makes little girls
who do love princesses
and who do love flowers
more open-minded to the world
of big trucks and machinery
and mechanical engineering.
I'm proud of who I am.
I am a woman, I drive big trucks.
(energetic music)